oh the beautiful new sounds of Rods
Simba and the regulator's I told you the
new musicals coming I couldn't wait any
longer he says to be nothing more than a
bass boom boom boom boom that is the new
hit from rod sim and the regulator's the
new song for whatever this podcast is
eventually gonna be called we're still
finalizing the name probably the left
coast show but I'm still digging it
either way rod regulator's you guys are
awesome I appreciate that was live music
with real instruments and it fit more of
my swag now I'm feeling all groovy and
calm and I'm feeling good you know I am
the MLB Adam Schefter I am breaking news
with Bryce Harper that was amazing but
the weekend of the combine was absurd
it's it's a weekend where we've spent
months going what matters is what's on
tape and in the eye in the sky and not
about running a 40 and then a guy runs a
40 in like 4-3 and we explode and we say
tear it up he's a top-10 pick but a good
show good good good coming we had Nate
Burleson who talked about everything
from maybe it is Big Ben and I'm about
to go into that a second and not a B we
talked about Jason Witten and he kind of
threw his a he didn't kind of he threw
his name in the ring to replace him for
Monday Night Football and talked about a
bunch of stuff in the NFL and then
Connor Rodgers of stick to football
podcast came in here and I sort of
downloaded some information about where
is the draft world right now what do
they believe is gonna happen at number
one who is the elite players he's he
kind of named 11 guys better seen is the
elite crop in this year's NFL Draft and
again I'm gonna have him at Matt Miller
in studio next Wednesday we're gonna
that will come out next Thursday and
that is gonna be me asking every
question so I'm probably gonna put out a
forum at the end of this week to ask
what questions do you want me to ask
those guys but I also think I'm gonna
the role of GM and tried and figure out
okay if I'm the chit's at 3:00 where do
I go
you know what do I do it for which
wide-receiver would you take number one
that's gonna be a good time it's one of
our most listened to podcast of all time
was the stick to football Simpson left
go crossover it should be good now I
need to have every week I went back and
I listened to the old podcast I'm just
gonna tell you homies how I do this now
and I realized I talked for like 20
minutes before I got to our interview
with David deal and then Phil Simms I'm
gonna try and keep it tighter and if I'm
gonna go on a rant or anything like that
a monologue I can only want to do one
thing and discuss the rest with my
guests I'm trying to make it a good
listening podcast overall and I need to
admit that I'm changing my mind about
something and a lot of it is because of
what I'm seeing how people are reacting
to this Antonio Brown stuff so you guys
know that I have been against Antonio
Brown and his actions for quite some
time now but as this story has played
out my players podcast sense has been
activated and right now I'm gonna be
honest I'm t maybe and I know that
doesn't make sense to a lot of people
but let me give the background to where
we currently stand and explained why I'm
worried so where it currently stands is
that three different national reporters
have put out the teams that are possibly
interested in a be Mike silver of NFL
Network has come out and said the Saints
and the Raiders Adam Schefter has come
out and said Washington the Titans and
the Raiders Ian Rapoport came out Monday
morning and said Cardinals Broncos and
that has been refuted and the Raiders
first thing do we see a trend three
different national reporters all said
the Raiders I'm gonna tell you right now
the Raiders are the likely landing spot
three first-round picks maybe they use
the last one to to get a B we've talked
before John Gruden's obsession with
veteran receivers and it's okay to be
obsessed with a B he's a hall-of-famer
it make
a lot of sense but if you take away the
Broncos as they've apparently denied him
the other teams Saints Washington Titans
Cardinals Saints would be great but I
still think the Raiders are the likely
leader when the time line has a speed
bump on March 17th March 17th is when a
two and a half million dollar bonus
kicks in for whatever team Antonio Brown
is on on March 17th its March 14th as I
record this over 13 days away that is
the day that whoever team he's on owes
them two and a half million dollars this
is part of Antonio Browns leverage you
got to get the trade done soon so the
Steelers don't pay him that bonus in the
meantime I think it's been clear to
everybody that Antonio Brown wants to be
a distraction to get moved already
he's on Instagram playing games against
high school kids gonna be honest not a
distraction just in the media but it's
the interview with Darlington on ESPN
and it's going on the shop again though
that was recorded a few weeks ago that's
put him at the forefront of the news and
he's saying things that would cause a
team to want to move on that's his
strategy solid PR get it done so that
you don't have to deal with this anymore
but I'm worried about one thing that he
said not for PR I think he's either
getting bad advice or he doesn't know
the extent of what's going on and it was
this quote from the Jeff Darlington
interview on ESPN if they want to play
they gonna play by my rules if not I
don't need to play obviously I want the
game but I don't need the game it's a
different you know I don't need to play
for no one like I'm happy you see this
paid off Kara no no one I'm a
millionaire Brahma entrepreneur like I
don't have to prove knowing anything and
I understand what he's saying and I
agree with part of what he's saying and
when he said look at this I've already
paid it off he sure
his like enormous mansion what scares me
is not not that this is gonna scare off
other teams because they're gonna think
that he doesn't need the game Antonio
Brown is so freakin competitive that
he's going to absolutely fight for
anybody but I don't think that a bu
realizes that if he sits out it will
cost him more money than he realizes and
if he does I apologize but I don't think
everyone else does if a B decides to sit
out for the Steelers that big time
contract that he had it was like 222
million dollars he's got to repay 11.4
of it by the way that 2.5 million dollar
roster bonus that he's gonna get on
march 17th he have to repay that too
that means that he'd have to pay back
13.9 of the 22 million that's 63% of the
number that everyone says is that big of
a deal that's my worry for a B I don't
need my players spending all this excuse
me spending all this cash figured it's
gonna be theirs and then all of a sudden
they owe back more than 60% of their
check my concern though what I'm
realizing is that everyone in the media
this is fans too but everyone the media
they all want to be Antonio Browns agent
they all want to be as manager his PR
person is crisis person but no one is
listening to a B they're saying that the
mustache had come off and the interview
should stop and that his solution should
be silenced and I understand you're
probably right but now we can learn from
his issues if we ever choose to listen
what I'm realizing is that everyone's
too focused going they see them on
camera and they go I mean look at this
mustache they gotta shave the mustache
and they don't hear a word he says or
they see him on camera and they go I
mean why is he doing another interview
he shouldn't be doing another interview
he should be being the good soldier and
sit back whatever but he's talking and
no one's listening they all want to be
as PR person and they're not
listening to the message Antonio Brown
goes on to the shop the episode that
LeBron James has has Anthony Davis and
Jamie Foxx and Meek Mill and everybody I
mean it's it was a great episode I'm
gonna be honest I really enjoyed it an
HBO pumped out two clips onto their
social media one clip about Antonio
Brown being the sixth round pick that's
now deemed a distraction and another
clip about his argument with Mike Tomlin
where he said you can just go home
you're beat up you can go home
but for some reason HBO didn't put out
the clip that truly Illustrated why
we're currently in a mess and that clip
is about Antonio Browns battle with Big
Ben that started the week in Denver and
I thought it was the most illuminating
of everything he said so it all talked
about the Denver throw and that was a
pivotal point of the season but you
could hear he said that's the kind of
guy he is the level of frustration that
has frayed between Antonio and Ben has
reached Erik and soluble differences and
I totally said that word wrong but don't
judge me on it I don't care and
differences that's embarrassing
but what I'm saying is it all goes back
to that game so I started looking at
that game
and I wanted to see what happened and
I'm wondering now why we didn't make a
bigger deal about big been throwing
Antonio Brown under the bus I read
articles after that Denver game I went
back and looked them up that said that
we should appreciate Big Ben being a
leader there were articles that said
this is what the two-time Super Bowl
champion is supposed to do holding
Pete's people's feet to the fire here's
what he said after the game Big Ben
talked about how juju was amazing all
day and he wished that he called that
play for juju then he threw Antonio
Brown under the
quote I can't tell if you would have
caught it or not but he did speaking
about the defense of Lyman undercut
Antonio who knows what would have
happened I told a B you have to come in
the flat
you can't drift in the end zone those
under cuts can't happen hey Ben you got
intercepted by Shelby Harris a defensive
tackle that dropped back into coverage
you cannot undercut a defensive tackle
he's literally at the point that is
closest to the ball at the snap and took
a step back and you're blaming Antonio
Brown for not going underneath him I
didn't even realize that when I saw it I
just said what a dumb decision by big
men I did not realize that he threw a
Antonio Brown under the bus and what
happened after that game people just
kick-started a three-game losing streak
that pretty much kicked the Pittsburgh
Steelers out of the playoffs and let's
say Big Ben wants to put it all about
that one play saying you know if he
Antonio Brown undercut somebody catches
that touchdown we're going the playoffs
really because in that three-game losing
streak do we remember what else happened
I remember what a Antonio Brown did
Antonio Brown went against the Chargers
in that primetime game and had 10
catches for a hundred and fifty-four
yards in a touchdown a B didn't fall off
but you know happened the game after
that it was that Raiders game where Big
Ben played the first quarter said oh no
I'm gonna sit out the second and third
quarter and tried to come back like
frickin John Wayne in the fourth but it
was too late and the Steelers lost to
the Raiders that Raiders game is pretty
much the reason the Steelers are we're
not in the playoffs
it's the reason Le'Veon Bell walking out
that door and Tonio Brown is pissed off
and Big Ben's sitting there going the
silence from Ben Roethlisberger right
now is deafening but I thought the most
interesting part of Antonio Brown on the
shop was what happened afterwards and
I'm gonna need you to go online and
watch this clip I have it on Sims and
left go Instagram
but it was the reaction to what he said
here so he said that the Steelers after
something like this a huge game in which
the quarterback throws his wide receiver
under the bus after he played very very
average and threw an interception to a
defensive lineman he said that Steelers
came up to him the organization and told
him to be quiet and say that he's wrong
but that not a single person asked why
are you upset
Tomlin didn't ask why you're upset the
coaching staff didn't ask why he's upset
the marketing the PR the social media
the everybody nobody asked well Antonio
Brown why are you upset they just told
him to shut his mouth LeBron is laughing
harder than he's left on the entire
episode and Jamie Foxx's in the room do
you know how hard you have to laugh do
you know funny something must be if
you're laughing harder than a Jamie Foxx
joke they're looking at him and they're
realizing wow you have no control you
have nothing and a be looked around in
that clip and he looks angry and
confused
because here he is thinking he's sharing
his pain with athletes and actors that
are gonna understand where he's coming
from and they don't understand they have
no idea because none of them in her
situation than Antonio Brown is in
Antonio Brown is a hall-of-famer
that's been working apparently in
lockstep with a man that shares an ego
the same size as his and it's completely
frayed and it's broken apart and Big Ben
is throwing Antonio Brown under the bus
and we're all taking the bait and
because Big Ben is being quiet we are
hearing
nothing it's a one-sided attack on a bee
should Antonio Brown lay low yes should
he do more interviews he has done more
than enough and it is very obvious but
he's also trying to tell us that the
Steelers might not be perfectly run
organization that we have deemed it to
be over these last few decades if it is
true that the GM of the Steelers is
correct that Ben Roethlisberger is the
adult in the room with 52 kids then it's
time we had a parent-teacher conference
who do children emulate who do they
learn from what are they a product of
the parents the adults so maybe we got
to this point with a B because he's been
learning from Big Ben all along
maybe he's just been emulating his
quarterbacks actions the laissez-faire
attitude the what I say goes really big
Benton kind of helped create this a B
but that's just my take now let's
welcome in Negroes what do you know I
went back and looked at 2003 NFL Combine
and the man with the highest vertical in
his draft class 42 and a half inches
that's right Nate Burleson Nate how are
you my friend
intro these old legs used to have some
hops in them found 42 and a half I mean
were we going between the legs dunk - is
that what you're capable of listen
between the legs
dunk I had to hand down my knee windmill
I even showed my arm to rim like Vince
Carter at 61 so you know your boy had
crazy that's unbelievable
what what is it like to watch the
combine now being so far removed and
knowing what it means to these kids you
know it it's it's fun to watch it
because the guys have gotten so much
faster
so much stronger and you know to be
honest they're better football players
that's the way the game is supposed to
be you know I remember in 2003 getting
there and I'm seeing some of the best
players in the world all the guys that
I've heard about you know Carson Palmer
charles Rogers Andre Johnson Antoine
Bolden and I'm looking at these dudes
and I'm like oh snap
there is now it's time for me to measure
up against them in my group we had Andre
Johnson and I knew I run a decent 40 and
I knew I'd jump a good vertical and he
didn't want to test and he need to test
because he was that damn good right and
I remember I did my bra jump and this is
after the vertical so at this point I'm
like to do with the house and I remember
him I pulling off his sweat and like
getting competitive and being like look
I said I wouldn't test him but I'm out
to do this Roger cuz you want to prove
everybody like they do got hops we got
half like me and sure enough he wasn't
lying
that dude went out there and leaked a
good jump but um it's good people call
the underwear Olympics you know and some
of it is because it's guys with the
shirt off running fast and lifting
weights but I think majority of it
because the NFL does such a good job
inviting a majority of these individuals
it will translate like DK Metcalf I mean
come on fam like what's going on with
the game like what are they feeding
these kids doing went out there and blew
the world away it's funny I'm gonna
mention this later with my interview
with Connor Rodgers from stick to
football but everyone's forgetting you
know DK Metcalfe's uncle was Eric
Metcalf and if you don't know that name
then you don't know the history of the
NFL and it's funny sometimes I feel like
the only bloodlines that get mentioned
is if you're a Bosa or if your dad
played quarterback - and when I started
hearing that his family was defensive
lime in the NFL and wide receivers in
the NFL oh no there's a track record
here this might not just be some huge do
that's but let's barreling down at four
three three exactly you're right about
that it's either the both of those
Manning's and then after that the
conversation kind of stops
you know Terry Terrance and of course
Eric Nick has is who he just mentioned
it's funny you said there's a track
record now there's literally track
records
Eric Metcalf was a speedster on the
track so the fact that you know he has
people within his bloodline I could
teach him how to run
really fast 42 shootout lowered
trajectory and then extend your legs
high and run through the line and glory
by the way with a 433 you know
everyone's deep with me because aramaic
has settled in seattle and my junior
year i ran on this track team the
seattle Express and I was a full-time
three Sport athlete sometimes for me
were for basketball
he was like Nate listen man you're
really good at hurdles come out for our
track program running track in a summer
bro Prefontaine I just come out and
check out some of the competition around
the world and I went to own a track meet
Invitational and in Texas and that's
when I saw real speed for the first time
like it's cool to run Seattle yeah fast
dude but when you're running against the
best from Florida the best attackers
best in Cali that's when I realized oh I
better take these spikes off and put
these cleats on for us my life because
yeah I mean I'm fast but I ain't fat fat
no no so before we had you on I was kind
of ranting about Antonio Brown and how I
flipped to his side I would say that for
a long time I found myself being Pro
Odell and because of that anti Antonio
Brown because for years I was going why
is he not getting in trouble but Odell
is being eviscerated but now I'm
watching everybody make a sideshow out
of Antonio Brown and I'm realizing that
nobody's listening to a single word he's
saying we're commenting about his
appearance or I can't believe he's still
talking and I'm going there's a lot of
truth to what he's saying and I'm
curious if you see any of what I see if
you slow down the propellers of the
helicopter that is going on going into
training camp if you can keep your eyes
off of his mustache or some people
saying that haircut that looks like
Coolio if you quiet what might be
distracting you because you're not used
to a flamboyant charismatic soon-to-be
Hall of Fame wide receiver if you just
pay attention to his words he's saying
something that we all identify with
that's working with somebody that you
might love that you have an appreciation
for but
the relationship has grown so strained
that it just isn't beneficial to being
any more and I remember when I was going
down and I was on TV and you know need
working for the network in CBS you know
people think I protect the shield I
don't protect the league like that's not
my thing
the league doesn't define me they may
cut my check but they don't define me
more than anything I protect players in
their perspective so I'm trying to hit
it from both sides all right here's a
big bin stinking big grid stinking I'm
the man
I'm assuming to be hall-of-famer while
receiver I'm the captain of this ship as
we go I go all right cool Antonio's
saying okay but you're only as good as
the wires you throw too and I'm the best
in the game even when I said I fell off
this year I put a 15 TD so when you talk
to me talk to me with a level of respect
versus talking to me like you would talk
to Judah who just got here
now as Antonio starts to open up a
little bit more and becomes transparent
about some of the issues I don't think
it's really surprising and this isn't a
bash big bin but if you really pay
attention to some of the things that
both of these guys have done and I
followed him closely because I played
against them and now I cover them
they're both tremendous talents they
both should be in the Hall of Fame
especially if a Antonio Brown stays on
the path he's on Antonio he gets
competitive yells and screams he's
flamboyant he got to change the clothes
commercials the money the flash to
possess all that but at the end of day
do work his ass off I mean I don't know
if you follow a B I encourage everybody
out there to follow him every social
media platform the one thing that
fascinates me most about a B is he'll go
on vacation he'll bring his nutritionist
yep he'll bring his trainer so find a
weight room he'll train by himself or
train with other athletes to train with
quick kids and we're talking about dude
chilling with his own kids but still
taking time to work on his craft and I
will tell you right now not every guy
does that your favorite player doesn't
do that now on the flip side big man you
workers butt off you don't work like
Antonio Brown Big Ben may you may be
passionate but sometimes his passion
doesn't come across saying there's a
beef
I'd rather take a guy that you might
occasionally described as a jerk
and and say he's too passionate about
the game then a guy that sometimes is
emotionally disconnected and that's how
sometimes I'll describe Big Ben
they've been expatiate fired up
sometimes hit you with the tiger place
and you like that dude
Kendall why throw a bachelor like him
that bossed on that say balls tremendous
that connection with him Antonio's
that's the truth but then there's times
were Hill walking life let me say well
you know maybe I ain't got it
I don't know I don't know maybe I got it
you guys know what you're talking about
I didn't start doing a radio show on all
season say and I'm thinking about
retiring two years in a row there by the
wall over Big Ben
whoa we want you we need you I don't
know if it's official compliment
just being honest nothing is they like
and tell their Browns not saying that in
a locker game maybe I got it oh you
don't think about retirement the only
thing I told Brown say recently is I
don't need the game which you would hope
every athlete says at at some point
because they've established himself
enough as a Brandon and had have enough
money to say I don't need it so for me
like when you start looking at where you
pull the curtain back a little bit and
you look at quote-unquote antics or
things said things done if you really
break it down some of that
passive-aggressive stuff that Big Ben
was doing it might get on your nerves a
little bit more than whatever the
flamboyant over-the-top diva things you
might describe it and tell me about
going all this went down
it's a week it came out it was something
happened at practice I wasn't there I
didn't see which we know something
happened so just say we're gonna keep
everything in-house
we'll handle it behind closed doors
don't act like we don't know what's
going on and then maybe even more upset
in that same conversation he said and
you know I I tried to reach out to
Antonio Brown he hasn't come back that's
the most passive-aggressive thing you
could do to the world listening now the
procession is damn a beating we're a war
he won't even call he'll be back so
instead of keeping it house being like
that's my brother I'm a clock so
Monaco's doors we'll figure it out you
go start dropping little subtle details
about what or what may not be having it
within the conversation communication
visiting too
which ultimately drove Antonia Brown
crazy he's like man what am i doing this
is the high school I'm the best receiver
you ever had what are we doing here
young man 100% I say this all the time
I'd rather you insult me to my face and
then play the politics and get me in
trouble somewhere down the line and me
realize months from now that you've been
laying these traps that I've been
stepping in that's what it feels like to
me then and I and his silence been
silence is allowing him to kind of get
away with everything right now and it is
that and the silence is deafening we
would pay attached to it and here's the
thing there's some people that work
closely with that organization closely
Sam and they say Big Ben has been the
biggest diva in this organization for
years now I'm just a former player I
can't go out on a limb and say turn on
TV because I can't corroborate that and
I'm not in the field enough I'm not an
Insider where I'm gonna call and try to
investigate it but if somebody said that
to me right my purse response is I can
see that anywhere there's two or false I
just say I see now here's the thing with
all this said though be careful what you
ask for for both of you guys Oh Larry
you're right
Larry Fitzgerald came out and said you
know he needs to I don't think he
understands how he good he has it what
you said maybe no one's thrown a better
deep ball in this league than Big Ben
Roethlisberger maybe no one's had the
toe tap on the sideline maybe better
than Antonio Brown but sometimes with
great thing comes frustration and I
think you know nine years I know a lot
of a lot of regular relationships that
can't handle half that facts and if
you're Antonio's saying you know time is
a time to move on yeah you got to hope
you land somewhere were you playing with
the potential all the Famer because if
you're not and the system isn't for you
to get the ball every other play you
might not be that happy yes within that
system now on the flip side
Big Ben if you're sitting back saying
all right it's cool like a be the man
but we don't necessarily need him one
move all we got to do a lot of juju
success was because he's playing next a
true number one now don't get me wrong
juju is a beast and he walked T to be a
beast but I know what a fight plan
that's the Randy Moss and Cal
Johnson like being a number two in his
league bro it's its cake when you're
facing second tier and third tier DB and
ap is taking all the attention now you
also have James Connor and there's their
lady on bills so this this team in a
matter of months is dramatically
different and if your Big Ben wouldn't
you want to try to make it work versus
act like in a big deal speaking of next
steps and possibilities would you like
to officially put your name in for the
Monday Night Football gig I saw that you
did it on Twitter and I just like to
have some audio of it I believe that you
and the booth would be fantastic I saw
you on pregame of the Super Bowl
nailed it I came up to you during the
media night where you're casually
standing next to Bill Belichick and got
good answers Nate I think you're capable
of everything I'm just curious if you
want Monday Night Football
no I appreciate it first time I've ever
spoke about this hell yeah I'll take the
job and I would try to change the game
and and create a relationship between
Monday Night Football the
traditionalists that watch it that love
it that appreciate it
Umbridge that to this younger generation
that really talked different walk takes
different act different dress different
and I feel like I can do that you know I
came in in 2003 and I left in the
beginning of this new era athletes so
that's what I do every day that's what
we do every day bro I'm preaching to the
choir we have a certain language that we
speak where if you're 60 you can
appreciate us and if you're 16 you can
appreciate it so that's what I would
bring to Monday Night Football the only
thing is is I have too many jobs you
know what you're not doing Monday night
that was probably one of your free times
you're right there might be my free time
but listen you never know I don't know
what they're gonna do this year next
year but you know the game is about
evolving and hopefully I continue to do
that within its own network in CBS as
ESPN is in the plans in the future then
I'll be open for it this year I was able
in a matter of 21 days during the month
of December with good morning football
the CBS NFL today and then the two games
I did for Fox I was able to to work for
three
the major networks in a 21 day span and
that was me
just giving my hello to the world saying
here's Who I am here's how versatile I
can be and here's what you have to look
forward to in the future I love that I
think what a lot of people would really
help their brains to is we all grind and
everyone's grind is different and their
own paradigm of their grind is how hard
they work and we all want time off but
there's this weird supercharged man when
you know you're building something and
even if you're not seeing it right away
and all your boys and all your families
coming up to me like I don't know why
everyone doesn't see it yet and you can
look at them and go it's it's coming
it's coming and it's weird because you
don't worry about time off you don't
need it now we were eventually gonna
take it because we want to spend time
with other people but the grind is
self-fulfilling it almost motivates you
more to be that tired it's a beautiful
thing and I'm excited for what you're
building men now I appreciate that man
like I said I'm preaching to the choir
we are able to meet in person for the
first time this year and kind of rap and
really connect like one of the better
things out down all you with homicide to
getting studio with you again but also
just watch it from a distance now that I
know you call you a friend and a
colleague and this businessman appear I
see the grind as well so it's always
it's always a confirmation that you're
on the right track when you see people
on the same freeway run into success not
a lot of people know where what
direction this is going in at least they
think they do Arizona Cardinals first
pick I was just talking with people
where they said it is the worst kept
secret Arizona's going Kyle armory at
one and I want to talk to you more
though about how do you handle the egos
involved - Steve time text Josh Rosen
and go man don't read anything this
Kliff Kingsbury reach out and go you're
still our guy what does Josh Rosen's
supposed to be doing right now I'm
thinking about the other chess pieces
involved how do you handle these fragile
egos at this point yes I think with Josh
Rosen yes I have a face-to-face
conversation with them and while you're
being honest you also got to build a
and tell them you know you're not the
first alas to be in the situation right
and not telling them what's going to
happen but have them understand that
this is a crazy business and when the
draft comes you could be traded because
we want to go a certain direction I will
say this Peter Schrager early on was on
the fence about playing baseball
football he is like I say he goes
Arizona I'm like crazy and I start
thinking back to last year's driver
sitting in Dallas he walks in the day
before and says yo I got a feeling the
Browns are gonna go number one Baker
makes and I'm like I mean I love Baker
happy fighting for more but I don't even
happening he's like I just feel like he
won everybody over at this point there's
no more decision to be made crazy
now you fast forward the entire year
another Heisman another guy who was
undersized who didn't really get the
proper buss up until combine and in the
draft and I do feel like all of the
Eagles involved they understand you know
we had a we had Kliff Kingsbury on our
show
Peter was talk to him he kind of
pressure on pressure nominee he avoided
a couple questions he slipped and ducked
and then he did the doe parole he means
like I will look Peters like what do you
want a rope with outside he's like what
are you gonna do what are you gonna do
with that pig and what are you gonna do
a Rosen and he said Rosen understands
it's a business mm-hmm that's pretty
telling you know he said soccer I go
down to week she were rockin with he was
like nah we love Rosen he knows if
you're reading between the lines
I say that's calimary going number one
to the Arizona Cardinals you got a
Heisman winner handing the ball off to
David Johnson and Larry Fitzgerald right
officer instead trying to have the best
year my my left go PR for Josh Rosen
would be this I would in the time that
I'm still there completely befriend
Larry Fitzgerald and what I mean by that
is I'm thrown with them I'm going to
camps with them I am gonna be so loyal I
might even create a joint Instagram
account called Josh and Larry where I
just want to I want the people of
Arizona
to always respect me and I think the
weird thing about Josh Rosen is we're
still talking about him being this
mercurial guy that's based in ego and
could he handle being a New England
Patriot what would he be like in the New
York market I think that you align
yourself with a guy that everyone sees
as the consummate professional and by by
being around him all the time people
will believe that you've now turned the
page because I don't know why we still
have these negative thoughts about Josh
Rosen's personality and he played a year
in the NFL with no issue with no issue
and really no stability
none thought that offensive line was
destroyed yeah rookie coordinators
looking at a coach I mean they had
issues on top of issues here's another
thing people like Josh I just a tough
situation to play football you could end
up in New York
backing up Eli Manning okay there's
something to be an Arizona anymore why
I'm be for me like oh I don't get caught
up in Isis you guys that got hey let's
do a like what's the bad thing what you
probably get straightest I'm wearing it
another opportunity to prove himself
like all athletes been doing they hold
on like this is a good situation so once
you get traded no hey take your dick
take your pill to deal with it man
anything else the NFL that you want to
comment on the only other story that I
was gonna bring up is every year I think
we could argue that Bill Belichick is
the coach of the year and he never gets
it and I saw that he got an honor on
Thursday that no one's gonna talk about
so apparently he got the game ball award
from the fritz Pollard Alliance for his
commitment to diversity for doing quote
a very special job of leveling the
playing field in diversity and inclusion
in the NFL and my big takeaway was you
know we got court cases where people are
fighting to show collusion we have teams
in which there are sons of coaches on
every staff from Kubiak to Turner and
I'm not saying that those guys shouldn't
be there I'm just saying a we got all
that and the guy that supposedly works
so much that it's too hard to even
comprehend has enough time to be the one
fighting for the most inclusion in the
NFL so it can't be that
hard to figure it out but I thought that
Bill Belichick deserve credit and I
think you understand what goes into this
league and what doesn't get talked about
sometimes no question I mean listen I
was always told believe none of what you
hear and half of what you see so there's
stuff that you hear about there might
not be going on in the league and the
stuff that you hear about that does and
then there's stuff that you see in other
stuff you don't see and I think the
assumption is Boston the market I mean
they have their own misconceptions of
that city but individuals that I talk to
African American players that play for
the Patriots I mean Dianna branch is the
primary example one of my best friends
on and off the field and the first thing
I did was pepper more questions when we
played in Seattle and what is it like
playing with Tom and Bill Belichick
after organization and he was like it's
family and it wasn't him trying to left
the organization he was literally saying
like you know like everybody is equal
once we walk in I mean the approach is
different but tom is the man he got a
little flavor to him Bill Belichick
that's not do everything that's all see
that's not the same God behind closed
doors when it comes to family the guys
on the team keep on the front office the
organization craft is the man he takes
care of all his people like so for me
like I can only go by what people say
that I trust and all of the individuals
that I've spoke to and that's white
black other they have all said the same
thing about New England is that it's one
of the best organizations and that's
deeper than football awesome
Nate I'm excited to get you in here soon
we'll make time I know you're busy will
create an eighth day to make it possible
but I appreciate you man all right bro
all right man be well Nate Burleson I
don't even need to explain how much of a
rising star he is and I think the thing
that I appreciate the most about him is
their substance to the style and to the
sizzle and to the swag no one likes to
critique people on TV more than me just
because come on man that's my bag and
what's like I think it's been very
interesting to watch this last week
everybody piling on Jason Witten man we
knew after the first week
wasn't gonna work out and I think that
the Cowboys actually got themselves an
interesting situation you're bringing in
Jason Witten now to a locker room that I
believe dak and Zeke were going to try
and lead and now he's back and to watch
those two interact will be interesting
but I think ESPN also found themselves
in a very positive but now a very
difficult situation because they kind of
got a free pass it wasn't working out
they get to move on I think somebody
like Nate would be great
I saw the campaign from Pat McAfee those
are two of the young guys that see the
business that are also super engaged
online with social communities Instagram
Twitter and they're able to bring an
aspect to the broadcast that's very
different
of course I'm capable but I would have
to do the Joe Tessa tour and it's not
like I've done play-by-play on a
national stage oh wait I'm just messing
around but seriously if you want me to
do the game I'm down to do the game all
right let's go now and talk with our
main man one part of the stick to
football podcast Connor Rodgers to
figure out what he saw in his weekend in
it and now we are joined by one of the
members of the stick to football podcast
he's been in Indianapolis the last few
days soaking up the sights and sounds of
a medium-sized city that Peter King says
is stuck in the 90s Connor Rogers how
hard that's a really good description I
don't wouldn't call it medium sized yeah
it's closer to petite alright so I'm
getting right into it the storyline that
you left Indy going that's what
everyone's talking about right now is
what what do we do with dk Metcalf
that's the number one for me I'm I can't
find anyone that I loved
yeah great conversation cuz it's hard to
find someone that thinks Skylar Murray
isn't going first anymore like it's
almost a boring story line at this point
really I'm bored of it I just that
pervasive like everyone really believes
it let go we're almost at the point of
this draft where it feels like we
started pick three cuz everybody I talk
to you believes the Niners will not move
a tattoo if Nick Bose is there so if
it's Kyler and beau so what the hell are
the Jets doing at three Wow Jets back at
number three so a few
I guess that parts the storyline but
back to DK Metcalf I mean when you get a
guy that profiles close to Julio Jones
and Calvin you're sitting there saying
well why did it take this long and the
reason is he he fractured his neck this
year so it's pretty fair yeah it's a
serious injury but he's cleared he's
healthy he's an absolute monster yes
this point at around 63 to 28 that crash
Sims would say incredible body
yeah like and were 33 27 reps like 30 40
inch vertical yeah it's insane but but
now the big thing that everyone pointed
to was the three cone yep seven three
eight three cones yeah Leo at a 667 and
seven three eights like rough but as I
was saying to you if I draft DK Metcalf
and I put him on the outside and I say
hey 40 times we're gonna run as fast as
you can and if you're you got one on one
no one's really gonna stay and strive
we're gonna lob it up yeah and if not
we're empty and underneath don't like is
there anything to that do you think well
I think the questions the one thing I
asked was how much do teams value DK
Metcalf as a vertical guy and a
manufactured tuchis guy so screens
bubble screens anything like that even
it's not a screen because there is a
nuance to the route but a slant just
have him go over the middle maybe clear
out and have him run drags the point is
how valuable is he as just a deep threat
and a guy that can create after the
catch which we've seen him I mean when
you go back and watch the film before he
got hurt he cuts like a hundred and
ninety pound running back that's how
sharp his cuts are so ball in with the
ball in his hand why was he so bad two
three he's I don't know he's not a
nuance route runner so that is a
question I think there are questions
about his hands I don't really have them
because I've seen him go up and win yes
and one-on-one situations at the end of
the day comes down to this for me
with that profile and that ability
ability vertically
he's a round one player yes he's around
one player in a class that at wide
receiver was looking for one there was a
lot of athletes from the wide receiver
position I just look at DK Metcalf like
seven receivers ran under four four at
this combine and that's as many as the
last three combines combined yeah there
so that just shows you the upper
of speed but DK Metcalf to me as soon as
he ran I went there's he's going in the
top 15 he's going in the top 10 we've
just seen this so many times
Rashad Perryman ran that crazy 40 going
to the top 20 15 and he couldn't catch
Kevin white you know he ran that 40 was
mesmerizing because he was so big and I
feel like DK has even been more
mesmerizing than him I'm gonna have some
left go PR for what DK Metcalf should do
now but it just felt like all the Darius
head were BAE's it felt like the one guy
did the one thing and now we're gonna
overdraft him and I just felt like all
of the draft community was like nah
we've had him at end of the first early
second the whole time and I think when
you look at it well nobody believed the
rumors of the 4-3 and then he goes out
and does it so it's like okay we're all
in on this now and there's a lot of
things unpack here like this guy isn't
out of nowhere this guy was a top
recruit and he flashed early at Ole Miss
and then this year a lot of people were
like well why wasn't he the leading
receiver and it's like well he was and
then he got hurt at the time he was a
head of guys like AJ Brown and DeMarcus
Lodge two wide receivers on that team
that are gonna be drafted yeah I mean
Browns gonna go top 50 Lodge will be at
least you know under the fifth round
kick so he was in an offense with tons
of talent and he still was the guy he
got hurt right that's that's the
question here the teams need to answer
it can he stay healthy over a long
period of time when you're that muscled
up he doesn't have 1.6 percent body fat
yes you would die but yeah and you did
you've done bodybuilding so ya know the
realistic mark parts of County feel like
the best bodybuilders in the world like
stay between like three to six percent
mmm so it's just fun because he looks
like a bodybuilder but that's not really
at one point six person so obviously you
guys don't stick to football we'll break
down every nuance of the combine what
was the buzz about the quarterbacks
after they all performed in Indy I think
well it's a shame that Kyler didn't do
anything but he didn't really have to I
mean he came in any way to 207 he
measured in over 510 right
they really stretched him out okay it
seems like so yeah
they I mean they really do that kind of
stuff like two days beforehand they're
just pulling him yeah like Miller was
telling me like to hang him upside down
like craziest things I don't know but
you know how like legit that is
either way there are methods to the
madness but great for Cuyler without
even having to throw you look at guys
like Haskins and Locke like the armed
talents they're very Jackson from
Buffalo now is you know he's with Jordan
Palmer which if you're with Jordan
that's a good sign and yes and they're
all he's someone that I think a lot of
people were looking at hey six seventh
round it's probably more third or fourth
round so it's hard to pass up that
athletic exactly six seventy two fifty
strong arm so when you look at this it
still feels like a class to me where
Kyler Haskins and Locke are going in the
first round and and if a daniel Jones
slips in from Duke then we get the
fourth yeah it's hard to get excited
about
retired Stidham drafted without a doubt
they'll talk top fifty kind of picks so
are you and Miller an agreement on how
you guys stack your top three I don't
think so who would I think my gear I
think we both agree that Kyler Murray is
probably the best quarterback in this
rush I like Dwayne Haskins a lot more
than him yeah I do like Dwayne Haskins I
can just fall jumps out of it without a
doubt he's just a thrower I mean he's a
big pocket passer he's accurate to very
accurate in the intermediate throws yeah
that's what that's he is what you want
your quarterback to be in the next level
you don't need to see him because people
are like oh I would like to see him
challenge vertically more your your boy
former GM of the Jets Scott McLuhan was
here the GM of the Jets no yeah he was
and the Niners and Seahawks he was but
he came out and said that he that Dwayne
Haskins has Byron Leftwich to a tee and
I thought okay well does Dorian Haskins
have an elongated motion I think the
ball jumps out of his hand because I'm
watching the combine on Saturday or
Friday whenever he throw and I'm listen
to Jane you know Jeremiah talking about
how quickly he gets the ball at him yeah
I don't agree with that and I said I
said if you were to talk about mobility
and the fact that he's black sure but I
look at it more as he was getting the
ball so quickly out of his hands that
that's that's the advantage yeah that's
just the release isn't even on my list
of things to worry about right I mean I
look at julik and I see the athleticism
I see the mobility I see the arm
strength but with Haskins I see that
pinpoint accuracy and it it comes out a
lot faster out of Haskins hand in my
mind than it does lock saying and just
mechanically there are two different
do we get miles per hour when do we get
that doesn't that come out of a few days
and weeks out yes it's like not supposed
to remember my homes came out it was
like six yeah saintly backs and then
people are like Watson is below the
threshold John Watson's doing just fine
I think so too
so which what what is a narrative that
you're seeing in the media right now
after combine that you're going damnit
that's wrong
is there anything right now that you're
seeing oh it's interesting because you
guys have been studying this all year
long yep and I'm curious like there's a
lot of people like me that are making
snap decisions like what are you seeing
right now I think Montes wit had an
awesome combine I'm so happy but I don't
think he's somebody that was never added
the first round
like people were and now there's
conversation to him being a top ten lock
I don't even agree with that because the
film is the film he still looks a little
upright and stiff on the film right a
really productive guy and I think people
get so caught up you know what it is for
me in general is that now there's 90
first rounders and the day everything
settles down and comes back to reality
and there are 32 so I think the combine
hype with that is always gonna be out of
control I think Brian burns and Montez
sweat we're always in the first round
gotcha hey this was just agency and
Montez sweat being mocked up by the way
he was the guy that ran the for for 46
60 she's incredible and then I think
when it comes down to it oh I mean one
that is just everybody in the scouting
world was convinced that Albert was 265
pounds he's 287 and he's 6 foot 2 that's
such a monster difference a deliverer is
your Hill on this trap I can do a
hundred percent and Oliver was the
presumed top pick in the draft last
year's draft and then he fell off seeing
as how he was under sized and all that
but 287 you're making moves at that and
it's when it comes down to it people
were like well I didn't have a lot of
sacks this year it's like well if you
watch the games they don't go they roll
away from him run away from him they
double and triple him Navy just cut his
knees every play like at some point it
is out of your control
it's it Oliver this is gonna sound
really extreme but at times was like you
know nobody threw drew near drills for
years teams
stayed away from it Oliver mmm cuz
you're playing Houston he's a guy that I
I look at all the time I feel like
people are putting Edie Oliver and the
pass rusher from Michigan in the same
category John Garey and it's not even
tonight and I don't feel like they're
the same everyone I feel like the
scouting world said get ready for Rochon
Gary to blow you all away but realize he
has no production and and Oliver was
like he has all this production but I
feel like they're being put in the same
group somehow they are and another guy
in that group this one bothers me the
most is Cleon Ferrell because everybody
is like one Clemson yeah he's won two
championships he's been productive pass
rusher great run defender you know the
leader you want a character checks out
he one of the best interviews for every
team and when it comes down to it
everyone's like but he's just not
athletic and then him in rashon Gary
who's this athletic freak they have the
same three cone and four pass rushers
that's that's the drill yeah it is the
one so you're sitting there and you're
saying well why was this a narrative for
seven months when they just have the
same three coach what does rashon Gary
do better than Cleon Ferrell but all we
hear about is Rochon Gary in the top
eight in Cleveland Ferrell oh you know
nice safe middle the first round player
my curiosity stemming back to the
discussion about Arizona and I talked
about this earlier just in terms of what
would you rather have would you rather
have Josh Rosen and Nick Bosa or Josh
Rosen and Quinn and Williams whoever
you're more interested in or Kyler
Murray and then like a defensive lineman
that you get either at the end of the
first round or the top of the second
like which would you rather hell I'd
rather have Nick Bose and Josh Rosen but
the issue all stems back to they hired
Kliff Kingsbury and if you're bold
enough to hire someone that was let go
from a big 12 team and then you hire him
as an NFL head coach and I'm a cliff
like true there I love Kliff Kingsbury
actually really think it was a good hire
you probably got a listen to what he
wants to do a quarter I feel like you
have to run offices contracts are now
locked up with Kliff Kingsbury so if
this doesn't work it's over and that
that's really when it comes down to is
even if Nick Bosa ends up being you know
a twelve sack guy in this work a year
with Chandler Jones the defense takes
strides but Rosen isn't performing that
well and Kingsbury goes I can't run my
offense
you have to kind of let him fail we're
gonna have to give him the piece and I
just I can't bet against Kyler Murray
with Kliff Kingsbury like they will
score points I don't know what the rest
of the team is going to look like I
don't know how the defense is gonna
function yes that is an offense that no
matter what they're gonna score points
it really is everywhere that the
Cardinals are drafting him number one
Mel Kiper saying it he's apparently
going around town and saying it yeah
everybody's convinced that this is
happening now and now we're at the stage
of like Josh Rosen's getting traded
before free agency yeah so and not for a
first-round pick which is an awful
return if you're Steve caught this is
like the Battle of you know conflict of
interest clips coming in going okay cool
I've never won pick I can do whatever I
want
I've wanted Kyler Murray since he was in
high school yeah I get him in the NFL
awesome
you're Steve chyme you just traded up
for Josh Rosen last year and now your
return on investment is like a loss of a
buy a couple of rounds like you went up
to ten to get him yeah then in a year
you're trading him for what a second or
a third round pick it's you better start
winning fast because then everything
gets pointed back to you why is no one
talking about Quinn and Williams as
maybe the top pick this is a guy that
ran what did he run the 40 like a four
or eight oh yeah even even yeah at his
size - it's just tremendous he had a
10-yard split of a 169 which is a leap
firm which is better than Geno Atkins
and Dhamma conceal'd McCoy Marcel Darius
JJ Watt and cam Jordan you know we
athlete and what's scary is he's not
even close to growing into it so why is
it why am I always hearing Nick Bosa and
not Quinn and William I think that's the
Valor that Nick Bosa squads which were
very incredible it's the value of the
edge pass rusher it really is that's
crazy yeah because if you were to ask me
right now who would I rather have
Fletcher Cox or Von Miller I'd tell you
Fletcher Cox okay I'm like I'm a sucker
though for the edge guy totally got it
it's quite a cool name everyone's
calling it edge now yeah no yes I
totally I've read looking what would you
would you rather have Aaron Donald or I
don't know Aaron down special but I'm
down under Khalil Mac I'd rather have I
just think that just the way the game
has been going the interior pass rusher
is is impactful on every single
play and I feel like the edge it's
sexier the numbers are great but I'd
rather I'd rather have Fletcher Cox than
DeMarcus Lawrence yeah I think at the
end of the day it's it really probably
comes down to need here and this is the
problem with this so say Cuyler is going
one that's what we have to keep doing
yes
the Niners have drafted how many for the
Niners they cannot draft Quinn and
William there you go totally under so
that's why I just meant overall well
there's not people that believe Quinn
and Williams is the best player in this
draft okay good and I understand it
yep Niners have drafted the same guy for
three years in a row they need to go it
I have it
Bosa Oliver Quinn in one two and three
and they probably all get the same grade
but that's how I stacked it because I'm
once again a sucker for the edge pass so
there's something what to say when
you're Nick Bosa where he's been elite
at every level and since he was a
freshman at Ohio State he was she
attractive I think that does mean
something or I think when you're from a
family that's first round on both sides
yeah uncle and his dad or first rounder
same brother it's like okay I just feel
like the fail right here is is not but
now you know what's funny we talked
about that with Nick beau so but you
know we don't talk about that with dk
firkin Metcalf yeah his uncle is Eric
Metcalf I know if people don't know Eric
Metcalf I would say before we saw
DeAngelo Hall before we saw the kid on
Devin Hester Eric Metcalf and Brian
Mitchell were like the two greatest punt
returners in the history of the sport
not only that he has family that played
defensive line in the NFL oh he's got
NFL bloodlines yes not yet we talked
about it with Nick Bosa but that's a
huge selling point yeah I think it's the
recency thing like everyone knows Joey
right like I don't know how much people
really care about Nick Moses dad or
uncle dad current NFL fans if DK Metcalf
is the creation of former defensive
lineman and Eric Metcalf that's why he's
got one points against that body fight
vet it's incredible yeah Noah fan TJ
Hawkinson yeah two tight ends from Iowa
that I think caught my attention just
how fast they were but also the way
their bodies work like if the Patriots
traded up and got Hawkinson I would not
be surprised and that was
next Gronk for the next day perfect but
no offense I'm going main your tray
Burton was sighs you know you're the
speed and the agility and all that stuff
how early could these two tight ends
from the same school go
I think Hawkinson is officially in the
top 20 my gosh yeah I mean I've seen so
we're not talking top ten is hard for
them it's tough it's I remember how much
everyone loved OJ Howard yeah I mean
loved him yeah and then he goes sixteen
right and it's like oh we've been
talking having the top eight for five
months so with Hawkinson who is like a
late riser it's no one thought he'd
declare okay it's it's really a position
I get top six I better block or than OJ
Howard yes right yes no just have the
top end
I think OJ had a little more of the
scene right right right so I just think
in this world if you were to ask me
today would you like a premiere wide
receiver or a premiere tight end I think
the gap has closed just in terms of like
your ability with the the play action
going up as much as it had this year the
first Attila T I don't know I think that
gap is starting to close I can make an
argument that no offense is the best
weapon in this right that's what I'm
saying I think because it's one of those
situations where he gets labeled as a
tight end but I mean he's he's more like
and this happen to Evan Engram right
there big wide receivers and they both
block with a lot of attitude like that I
thing that does matter like you look at
and always undersized like no no he
throws his body around and then you have
the recency bias of George Kendall
breaking like all tight end records and
having on Iowa yeah so everyone loves
the Iowa tight end well as they should
as they should right now it seems
Hawkinson top 20 fantasy op 35 kind of
range he might be the guy when we're
sitting there on day two and everyone's
trading up formed at pic 33 34 35 mmm
all right let me ask you your own pick
then so you would say right now the
draft world is looking at Cuyler one to
the Cardinals Bosa two to the Niners and
then the first pick of the draft is
starting with three yeah who do you
believe the Jets would take at that
point mr. jet you call everybody you
possibly can and get out of so but if
he's done if you're saying if you so
that's my number one rule okay in
talking about the draft from now on is
every team in the NFL is trying to trade
down and take pics
but if you had to take the pic who would
you take who would I take her who would
they take both okay
that's Wow it's pretty straight would
you take I would really think about
taking Devon white really I really would
well su people are gonna sit there and
go you're insane
it's for me if they were running a 4-3
with Greg Williams the pic for me was
Cleveland Ferrell because he's the
perfect four three defensive end that
they need they're telling everybody that
I'll listen they're sticking with it
three four and he just doesn't he's not
gonna stand up right so you know on
value-wise I would like Cleo and Ferrell
there it's just not it's not a fit I can
make the argument for Quintin Williams
are at Oliver but everybody is like oh
that's the one area they don't need help
right so because the who would be the
edge guy there
everyone says Josh Allen it's just a
little early for me okay it's a little
early that's what I'm seeing in a ton of
yeah he's in the 15 to 20 range caliber
player for me every year we hear about
there's a certain amount of guys that
they're the upper level guys like I felt
like last year there was like the top
seven yeah how what do you think the top
is right now like name those guys nick
Bosa okay that just based on picks right
now so overall ratings okay for all like
what's the upper level when does it stop
it's Nick Bosa Quinton Williams I think
get Oliver still in that conversation
Devon white okay lie back so three down
linemen one linebacker so far it gets
tricky I mean I do think teams value
Kyler Murray that highly okay so he's in
the top five
yeah I really think Haskins is in the
top five like the top level
no okay no running backs no it'll be the
same Josh Jacobsen a lot of spots yeah I
think it's a little inflated right now I
think Josh Jacobs is in that 20 to 30
range wide receivers
maybe Metcalfe gets there okay I think
he's a fringe elite he's a fringe elite
guy still think he's in the tier to
anyone else that Notre Dame kid that ran
like a goose yeah I just I think those
are really far off it's kind of the blue
CH greedy was in the conversation for so
long and I was gonna say the quarter by
greedy Williams LSU was he in that
everybody cooled on him and then he goes
into running sub for for today and it's
like okay well our concern was turning
and running and I don't think that's an
issue right so greedy is probably in
there he's probably in any safeties no
linebacker you already said is it both
Devon's or just the one white
I think I blade bolt should be I think
everyone will tell you bushes tear - and
then the defensive lineman you said
there's like three yeah when you have I
mean Quintin Williams and out Ed Oliver
right there or Jeffrey Simmons was it
there he tore his ACL training damn so
but he was in there
what about offensive lineman or any of
them and then yeah John Taylor from
Florida has really found his way into
that conversation along with Jonah
Williams gotcha
so you would say right now that the the
elite of the lead of the lead of the
draft when it seems to fall off Kyler
Murray possibly Metcalfe but he's a
fringe guy yeah Williams and the kid
from Florida on the offensive line
what's his name is Juan Taylor would you
put the tight ends in there I would
definitely I put Hawkinson in there ok
so maybe a Hawkinson so Hawkinson and
Metcalf or fringe
yeah D lineman there's three Bocek
winnin and a Tolliver linebackers
there's one I would put Fant in there
with them you would put it's just a
positional value thing but I think
Hawkinson and Fant are fantastic white
as a linebacker greedy Williams as a
corner yep and that's it yeah I think if
byron Murphy tested a little better
it would have answered for the size
concerns but he's the classic of
fantastic corner ads wait for the
combine and you're like damn I I thought
he was a little quicker there so you
have 11 I just counted there's 11 but
there's three guys that are maybes and
that's very clean there should be in
that conversation okay so in 12 but the
the two tight ends and the wider end
Metcalf or the maybes yeah and you're
sitting there at three yep and it's I
guess greedy Williams is what the Jets
now maybe at Penn no rusher I think they
would take Jonah Williams because they
have no center right now and everyone
thinks he could be an all-star center
and then when Beecham's contract runs
out you moving to left tackle you guys
do need a line okay that makes sense
alright so can I run oh one more thing
we had a one of our guys the kid in the
Saints fan that was there for our show
he told me a while ago he goes mark my
words the wide receiver that's gonna be
the best in the NFL is Hakeem Butler
okay and he can and six five to twenty
seven and tastic combine four four eight
18 bench 36 vert what do you think of
this kid I just might my Saints fan gave
me the Nugget now he's he's Iowa State
yeah
okay but I got to see him this year I
went to TCU Iowa State and he didn't
have a good game he had two catches for
like 12 yards of course and I was
excited to see him and David Montgomery
I think it's another guy where there's
some separation questions but at the end
of the day when you're that big it
doesn't matter all the time I think on
boards right now he's early second round
mid second round I don't think he'll be
a first round player just because he's
you almost want to use him like that
seem tight end at times were you look at
him like let's not ask him to always win
on the outside let's just find a way to
get him the ball over the middle of the
field and in the red zone and he's fun
after the catch okay that a big guy like
you could you take him or Courtland
Sutton from that Courtland Sutton I
loved him okay yeah he's a baller I just
thought he was more of a receiver at the
time coming out all right so I have some
left go PR okay let's hear it for a lot
of the guys that performed great at the
combine it's easy for left go PR to do
the guys that didn't do great and go hey
show yourself working out you know show
yourself to be better times mm-hmm my
advice my left go PR for Kyler Murray
everything he involves himself with
should be small his shirts should be too
small his pants should be too small make
your limbs look bigger perception he
should hold small golf pencils all the
time and those little baby cans of coke
and take pictures with that everyone's
me like you know his what's up with his
hands it'll go viral and everyone will
be like maybe he's bigger than we
thought he was that's my left car for
caliber okay I think it'll work I think
the picture of him and Josh Rosen from
mm oh my god you can't wear pants like
that Kyler what are those
those look like Genco 's Hey that's
exactly what cinema janko's here's my
left go PR for DK Metcalf everyone's
talking about your 1.6 percent body fat
this is an idea for perception and for
product don't ever wear shirt go to IHOP
and take a picture in front of like the
all-you-can-eat pancakes with the
caption looking to build up on that 1.6
percent that will spread guarantee but
also maybe you lock up an endorsement
deal with IHOP kind of how like count
like Chad Johnson got a lot of
agreements with McDonald's
be the one restaurant that fills him up
and I got I got to be more healthy
I got a he's the only guy that needs
more body fat and it's a great
perception for IHOP because then people
think of jacked TK Metcalfe when they
exact ten pancakes in front so I want
three percent of that deal now I got one
for Montez sweat okay Montez sweat just
go volunteer at a hospital and get the
local news crew there because what I'm
thinking is is this is a guy that blew
up on the combine and now all of a
sudden teams are going is he gonna be
our first first round representative and
then all of a sudden he shows up and
they go wow he's good is a great guy
that's a great guy he could be the face
of our draft class you just got to show
that you're the number one guy and I
feel like that's one of those like
subversive subversive actually what
feels good about the player Andy
Isabella is this one I wasn't expecting
this it's the white guy from UMass that
ran a four to seven he could fly I've
heard three no he was a hand time just
see what happened with his times no he
was clocked unofficially at four or five
two and everyone's like Oh Mike this is
horrible like he's been telling us sub
for four and then it was in the four
threes how does that have I don't bets
arable though and happened twice to him
Charlie Casserly I believe that Andy
Isabella should do a what did Kyrie do
or he dressed out like the old guy uncle
drew uncle drew he should do an uncle
drew on a track but he doesn't need to
dress up he should just do the white man
can't just but it should be white man
can't run so he should just walk out
there and go you got y'all trying to
race and then just burn people he needs
to be wearing like shorts though and yes
and a tie-dyed shirt yeah yeah and he
goes out there just burns Pete yeah or
he goes out there and he goes to an
Atlanta Braves game and he races the
fries or whatever that dudes that's the
money idea and just SMO or he does the
fries to the fries and then pause like
takes off the mask or whatever yes feels
it's him yes auntie Isabella needs to
lean into this I think I read a lot my
last one is for I think your favorite
player this
draft I think your your two favorite
players are Devin why yes and I'll
that's correct
those are your two I think so I just
need to know where everyone's biases are
so yeah I know I'm extremely biased on
everyone's bias yes like my DK Metcalf
bias
I'm overeating the both of them that's
okay yes that's just good for us to know
my left Co PR for a doll avert is to do
combine workouts on the farm so ed
Oliver came out and said that he has our
horses and he used to own a horse named
Oreo who helped him become fearless
quote I'm able to go up and play against
six five 300 guys it's a walk in the
park I was fighting with a 1000 pound
animal I'm not worried about 300 pounds
so what do I need for met Oliver instead
of flipping a tire I need you to flip
the hay bail I need to see him going
toe-to-toe with Oreo I need to see him I
want to see I want to see a horse that
looks like it's trying to pull a truck
with all its might but as you zoom out
he's pulling against ed Oliver and at
Oliver's pulling him back it's perfect
for him he's the most country player in
this Jennie I love how like he's so
authentic
today he is like this is somebody from
Houston that just like I'm gonna stay in
Houston like he literally said I'm loyal
to the soil
I want the low of the soil like that I
want it to be like the rocky four
montage when he's in like the the barn
yeah and he's just like oh I want to add
Oliver dressed in overalls and like a
crappy shoe a straw hat maybe yeah okay
yes to sledgehammer so our door now how
do you do this when Devon white actually
owns like six horses
oh so can you do something for Devon
white with perfect this is what I'm
doing with Devon white left go PR he's
more based in speed for for guy I want
to see him running along the rail next
to a horse and then that way we get the
Instagram holy crap Devon white is
faster than a horse or the check down
comes with some like what's the
horsepower of Devon white but that's
pretty good if you're faster than a
horse you know what go to Lexington go
to Keeneland get into a starting gate
and race a horse I mean I'm getting this
for its really good I really want to
come back and have you do the guys that
had bad weekends and like they've a
let's save them alright so you have a
what do you guys got going on for stick
to football this week so we're gonna do
more we recorded our show half way
through the combine and because of the
release time and then we did mention
like the DK thing and all that stuff but
now you have all these defensive ends
that just went absolutely insane on
Sunday so we'll finish all that up
Wednesday a ton of rumors cuz free
agency and franchise tag deadline stuff
so we'll recap all that I don't think
we're gonna have any surprises with the
franchise tag I mean it's pretty obvious
the only two guys that are up in the air
right now are CJ Mosely with the Ravens
and Landon Collins with the Giants the
other ones are very obvious so recap all
that will have Miller here in studio
next week yes and we are gonna do a
super joint pod next Wednesday for us
it'll come out Thursday where I think
I'm gonna be half GM okay listening to
you guys go up and back on on possible
prospects but also I don't think we're
there yet I I still feel like the mocks
are starting to be formulated more of I
just want to get downloaded from you
guys
Who am I paying attention to where are
the cutoff lines at every major position
group you're gonna love this you're just
gonna milk you I mean me and a merge is
more different than ever this year I
think in a really good way I mean we're
both Devon white like you know stands
yeah yeah but a lot of difference of
opinion there so you have a lot of you
just have to scouts bickering at you and
you picked the decision Mick I don't
know if you got a cued up but if you
want to give me that funky music I would
appreciate it because Connor has wrapped
this up so darn beautifully according to
Connor it looks like right now Kyler
will be the first pick in the draft or
into the world right now as well by the
way this is my new theme song it's it's
absolutely amazing and I've heard rumors
it's custom it is constant don't forget
that rod Simba and the regulator's oh my
god it's just guys you were the best
homies you are awesome hit me up on
social as always we will holla at you
later holla holla holla for conner
Rogers I am the lef koe
left go man thanks dude
see you guys be well
[Music]